Stokley pointed out you know I always
refer to stokeley's uncle Stokely would
always say that you know we have to
define racism and racism is if you if
you want to lynch me that's your problem
but if you had the power to lynch me
that's my problem right and so it's a
power construct and it's about systems
right
it's about systems and institutionalized
racism and so one of the things that
I've always always always talked about
is the fact that if you take if you take
this pandemic if you want to peel the
layers back you would appreciate this
because now we have data we have data
that shows us that black people are
dying disproportionately the Native
Americans and the question is why and I
go back and I'm like it's not just you
know get more vitamin B stop drinking
and stop smoking it's the fact that as I
outlined in my vanishing country like
you know you grow up in a food desert
where you can't have healthy food
alternatives you you're drinking dirty
water you're breathing in polluted air
you know you you live next to a
brownfield or a manufacturing plant
you're going to schools that are broken
down I mean all of these things
contribute to the comorbidities
contribute to the preventable diseases
and then you overlay a pandemic I mean
hell like you know the same when America
gets the gets a cold black folk get the
flu well now America has kovat and black
folk are dying and that is the reason
why because of these systemic and
Justices we have in this country and so
right now you know racism and those
systemic great racism is killing people
two ways through kovat and you know on
the streets or at the hands of law
enforcement and you know we haven't we
haven't really addressed that and one of
the ways that you know we've peeled the
layer back when we look at the data I
think that you know when you talk about
a UV ubi that is one way to that's one
way in which we can help improve some of
these systems and improve the culture in
many of these communities to me Bakari
and I said this on the trail words hurt
numbers kill I know if you have systemic
poverty and people have high blood
pressure and all these I you know
diabetes and all these health problems
because they live in a food desert their
food intake
there they don't know where their next
Brent check or paychecks gonna come from
that's also very very stressful you know
you have like elevated elevated mental
health problems and anxiety and
everything else that like the numbers
are the the thing that we can actually
address if we all get together as a
country and say hey guess what we're
tired of people being poor $2,000 a
month and this is what Martin Luther
King was fighting for when he was killed
and you know Timmy his memories has been
sanitized do you have this like
celebrate his birthday like you know I
have a dream and it's like you know you
don't say you don't see every freaking
year it's like Universal basically give
everyone